broccoli eternit
oggi nuova challenge e vedete che se la
trattazione di una serie di ingentissimi
saremmo andati da farne un'altra sempre
con il cibo sempre quella volta abbiamo
deciso di fare la panchina avevo pensare
che si possono mettere vari strati di
questo dentro il funky con il vino sarà
peggio sono così felice perché pensi che
per i maggiori ma intenzionale capito
cosa storta challenge andremo a girare
la ruota e qualsiasi per niente ci
capita dovremo mettere due militari
strati di pancakes quindi iniziamo dal
primo strato poi secondo e così via
alla piccola di strass anti dovevano
mangiare i fan che cosa ci sia dentro
[Musica]
l'altro
quindi se volete vedere altri salesi con
la nota per il singolo da quel laiche
registi aleksandrova coronata 16 pure
con quale altro cibo potremmo farla che
si può infine partito con lasagna per
iscriversi nei commenti consigliatissimi
commenti mettetevi comodi far rapire
boss corner
abbiamo subito potete fare tipico un per
meglio e si bombarda italia da fine del
video potrete gustare
[Musica]
non testa oddio no ma l'inter merita c'è
questa voce sono dei predetti buoni il
primo che vi capita proprio un silo 40
specchia perché quando un cutter vittore
ancora perché c'è anche lo scambio è
scambiato il messaggio quindi il primo
strato di pan che
[Musica]
che buono
mamma mia ok dove stiamo bene sociale
preoccupante dai prof
[Musica]
madrid cambierà scambio abitato lì muore
come software si appella a chi da intero
ecco qua il mio primo strato di pancakes
bello piccante magari diventeranno dei
pancakes salati limone anzi dal
packaging anzi do è ok piccante
[Musica]
marvel ha parlato con il cielo
allora devo passare al prossimo
contratto però non so come ci sarà poi
da quello strato andato bene e bastare
per volere che fosse tutto un cuore tu e
mezzo per me lo zio magari scopriamo che
francesca benissimo i dolci piovere
tuffo para di assaggiarlo
[Musica]
meno male che si sta benissimo le banche
con la stella nell'hotel come le crepe
sulla prossima volta
da saltare la combinata manara
probabilità è veramente non figuri la
bara nella marmellata
chi vorrebbe per anzi a me non mi piace
[Musica]
prego non so magari qui abbiamo dai
cazzo
[Musica]
fortuna cioccolato kinder toronto mesi
per i moniti mostrato tanto che si rompe
certo poi anche a bramare tanto
dirotterà lucani banking va benissimo
[Musica]
che non ci facciamo ballo tasti
mescolato cercano si fermerà solo
broccolo broccolo
[Musica]
ma che però cina banana sta benissimo
quindi due strati di peperoncino
allora ecco il mio l'ovetto kinder beppe
rosso per buono un prodotto poi il tempo
come quello zio e il limone invece con
l'importante che ci abbiamo un
palloncino sopra davvero in cina sotto
che ha martellato al 100 ancora due
strati per me e tre e tre per te a2 e la
stessa perché in question time al genero
niente ma io ancora devo chiudere quello
quindi uno per me 2 per terra io ci sono
quasi
e poi c'è anche nello strato di sopra ha
pure
[Musica]
non mette niente
ciao
no no no io speravo il blocco anche la
del vicino è nuovamente i limoneti e
tanto però è preso bene brevi il più bel
gioco broccoletto nord potrebbe ancora
capi tardi anche a te come mai procuri
di nonché impropria sono tanto ecco
non ti butta proprio piccolino grazie
guarda
bello bellissimo è diventato un in sala
cake vederlo brocco uni un pan salata
rosso l'insalata cioccolato sarebbero
più tardi anche a te oppure potrebbe
uscire uno scambio arrivo
[Musica]
fortunato perché è capitato lo sviluppo
d'angelo che è la cosa più buona dei
pancake annuncio messo il limone quindi
per me lo dà l'ultimo strato di internet
aperto l'ultimo strato tutto il limone 0
pt troppo da cielo sembrano quasi punk i
normali dal proprio da bari o
peperoncino credit union io sono a posto
completato il mio qualche link c'è un po
di peperoncino un po di limone ma va
bene io devo ancora dire la tua volte e
potrebbero uscire scambio diamo stesso
scambio magari quei doni
ho sbagliato veramente devo dire che
spesso la cosa
il proprio leader o madri tu invece cosa
che un bando per palacio bene alla
marmellata è noto ma quello che s'è già
caratterizza lo metto pure nel contempo
dal quale l'ultimo strato lotta bella e
buona
quindi facciamo il conto di tutti morti
i credenti vuole quanti critica
ehi me non hai mangiato ad ora denti il
resoconto con le cooper oncino ciò non è
il primo dato che aimo peperoncino e
proprio show del brutto leone va bene
che i bebè renzino due avanti 2 0 0
quindi vedi te l'ho fatto pure buono
vabbè ho giocato tanto adesso da è che
allora prima media con sé un pezzo
vediamo un po come a proprio amenta
[Musica]
hamburger che può disporre di una bella
fetta che deve includere tutto è bella
fetta che da piccolo di tutto
soprattutto cioccolato e di limone ma
soprattutto riflettere tutto imboccando
raffreddamento più distratti proviamo
[Musica]
come vino sta bruciando così lo stesso
mamma mia
[Risate]
quindi solamente da un manto di tutto
l'uomo sia a quello stona un po ma gli
screen che sapore ha si sente molto il
limone proprio il vino o marmellata
amaro e vabbè tanto perché che su un
dolce credo che te lo fanno spesso ti
piace lo stesso quindi che vuoi fare
quando vengono fuori cioccolato no no se
lo vuoi mangiare un po tutte assieme il
nostro cioccolato
anzi ti va bene lo stesso ma davvero
tutto
io ora c'è pure peperoncino quindi il
mart bang anche peperoncino però adesso
vinciamo tutte le volte che ha mai detto
di no
[Musica]
ecco perché non mi tirerei di fare per
spezzarle derby da migliorarlo non se ne
sto a tagliarlo bene ci sono i verdi
rossi io e peperoncino solo due volte
quindi mi voterà bocca di cioccolato
aiuto come faccio proprio lo zio
iagrosso però i medici non me la prendo
tutto mangiato tutto com'è tutto per un
cinema si sente
la banana ammorbidisce un po il sapore
acido ma ficcante peperoncino quindi
quindi ho vinto io ma si mangia di più
di più devi mangiare
non voglio associare dosaggi il mio voi
broccoli e no a giulio come allora non
lo stato beh eventi sì secondo la lingua
devo però quando mi crede tutto si
effettivamente un po pi cantello ma ti
piace di più questo il tuo al mio ci
sono più fondi ad oggi che il cioccolato
salame di cioccolato di modica
cioccolato la marmellata lo sciroppo
d'acero con cui però c'è il broccoletto
prima va bene non so niente
perché vitale prima non erano tutti lo
stesso quindi noi non c'è nel tour
pericolo e ora vi lascio qua il
sondaggio in cui potete votare se
secondo voi ho vinto io
stanno partendo pezzi se secondo voi ho
vinto io o se ha vinto italia in base a
quello schifoso
scrivete voltate e scrivete nei commenti
secondo quello che scrivo dopo non me lo
schifoso mi sta piacendo cioccolato ora
vi lascio con quattro piante linee su
cui potete cliccare per vedere nostre a
300m quella che pulite buona visione
ma ora basta non si parlavano poco
vivace